why men cheat mostly cleared I were
talking about on average you know
because people's country for a variety
of different reasons but on average men
cheat because they have this desire for
sexual variety and so you see this in
some clear cases like I have to pick an
older example a Hugh Grant
Elizabeth Hurley drop dead gorgeous
um model actress whatever and then he's
caught you know having sex with a
prostitute on the street and L.A like
what's going on he's not he's basically
trying to satisfy his desire for sex
right and people look at that and think
he's crazy because you know he's he's
with this gorgeous woman
what is he doing but that's not that's
not that atypical and because
a primary reason for men
cheating is this desire for sexual
varieties it's not because
um she's better looking or higher inmate
value it's just that she's different
literally yeah yeah whereas for women
the primary motivation and not the
exclusive with primary motivation for
Affairs is because they're unhappy in
the relationship and they're looking to
either get out of a bad relationship or
an unsatisfactory relationship or
looking to trade up in the mating market
so this is the the mate switching
hypothesis is it true that
of saying that men cheat to stay and
women cheat to leave then well uh I
would say the second is definitely true
women women cheat to leave it now we're
talking about like about 70 to 80
percent of women this is what studies of
women who have had affairs this is what
their primary motivation is is to get
out of a relationship or trade upwards
or segue back into the mating Market
um whereas men it's more like
um Chris Rock had this quib of like men
are only as faithful as their
opportunity now that's an exaggeration
opportunities who don't act on them
um uh and it's true of men and women we
have opportunities and we we choose not
to act on them for a variety of reasons
it could be don't want to jeopardize the
marriage don't want to
um sacrifice my reputation in the eyes
of other people don't want to
um you know write it variety of reasons
why people choose not for religious
reasons or moral reasons or whatever
yeah let's hope that let's hope that uh
Integrity comes into that yeah yeah well
so like a prime example was
um uh and you may be too young to
remember this but there was uh with uh
President Jimmy Carter uh he did an
interview at Playboy magazine a long
time ago and he said he had uh lust in
his heart and that he had committed many
adult Victory many times in his heart
but as far as we know he never acted on
that
um but he confessed to what I think most
men have is they have this
ferocious desire for sexual variety
um and but some act on it when the
opportunities are there or the costs and
risks are low but many don't act on it
and his case as far as we know he never
acted on it and was always 100 percent
monogamously faithful to his wife
Rosalind I don't think it's the right
question to ask why do men want variety
I'm going to ask instead what is it that
each gender wants sex for and what does
it mean to them like what what is the
sexual psychology for a man versus a
woman that would lead to then of course
why men want variety
well that's a great question and um a
deep question because I mean it gets to
the heart of our evolves sexual
psychology the reason that men have this
desire for sexual variety and it's
different from for men and women and
it's not that women have zero desire for
sexual variety but it's just that it's
low on average compared to men and and
there's so many examples of this so just
descriptively a man can walk down a city
block and pass half a dozen women and
have
thoughts about sex with that woman
within a span of two minutes
um and and I don't think women do now
women do become attracted to you know so
I hear you know even women who are in
stable relationships you know that uh
John uh Jon Hamm playing Don Draper you
know people become infatuated Don Draper
or uh or George Clooney
um or I don't know who I guess some
younger uh Ryan Gosling uh and and I can
think of a few yeah yeah or historic I
don't know where Brad Pitt stands but he
used to be a sex symbol when women just
like with croon over uh Brad Pitt and
perhaps have sexual fantasies about Brad
Pitt but
um but it's just like uh it's a it's
it's just still a massive difference uh
and this shows up this the sex and
friendship shows up in things like
a number of sexual thoughts per day
uh men how many more than women a number
of different people you have sexual
thoughts about men much higher than
women
um consumption of pornography about 80
of the pornography is consumed by men
then women and even the nature of the
pornography is very different you know
with men it's just there's no plot you
know there's like maid comes into the
hotel room
to clean up the room and within 10
seconds they're having sex uh you know
whereas women's pornography tends to be
more have some some plot some context
some romance
um and uh so is even the nature of men's
and women's sexual fantasies are very
very different and this shows up for
example in I don't know if you've ever
read the stanika but like the the
romance novels like uh the they should
be called bodice rippers you know where
you have on the covers this like rugged
uh handsome dashing on some man who
happens to be a uh wildly successful
businessman or a prince or whatever he's
like off the charts and status
women desire him uh many women and but
he finds himself uncontrollably drawn to
this one woman sort of against his will
and and it's the modern day Fifty Shades
of Gray guy Christian Gray yes yeah yeah
exactly and um and you can bet who's I
mean who's it so these these romance
novels it's actually the largest
uh selling book category in the
publishing book publishing industry I
mean it's a multi-billion dollar
industry uh and um and it's a 95 of the
consumers of those books women are women
because men like to watch it and women
like to read about it yeah and and and
yeah it Taps it an entirely different I
mean it highlights the difference
between male and female sexual
psychology and and is it an imagination
thing
because like as like a low-level example
like you can say to a guy like oh what
should I wear and he might not be able
to kind of picture he's like I don't
know put something on and I'll tell you
like and a girl can go oh I don't know
like maybe like a cute little black
dress with you know like um some shoes
some like kind of boots like what do you
have for like a girl might have this
vision of what something should look
like in a guy's like I don't know I need
to see it yeah yeah no I think that's
exactly right and
um all the studies point to exactly that
that with men the visual sense is
overwhelmingly the primary sense whereas
women it's uh it use a much wider range
of senses that are involved in their
sexual attraction you know so
touch sound
mood context setting up and then to your
point about these different um
imagining different
dress scenarios I mean women are just
more uh they devote more uh time
attention and effort to even thinking
about those things and have a most
people don't know this they have a much
richer color vocabulary oh
um than men you know it's a man it's
like well there's there's like green and
red you know or and and for women they
have like six different words for green
well there's teal and there's short
green and there's you know mint yeah and
then yeah Christmas tree red versus
emerald green yeah and yeah yeah so um
so even women have this much richer
um sensory vocabulary for colors
uh so um so that's another that's
another really interesting sex
difference
um but but anyway so yeah so you get
these these fundamental sex differences
in our sexual psychology and then that
they play out in the real world
um and sometimes catastrophic ways
um and they also even
they can they play out within
relationships themselves because if you
figure so men have and this is again
this is maybe Politically Incorrect say
this but all the data show this is that
men have a higher sex drive on average
now there are women with very high sex
drives but men on average have a much
higher sex drive this is another myth
because men's sex drive tends to be sort
of that
it's called 20 range 25 like 18 to 25
feels very high but then for a woman
it's like later 30s yeah but yeah for
when for when it Peaks right another
myth in like yeah which men and women
are miscalibrated yeah so so in terms of
sex drive ideally what you want you know
is a 35 year old woman with an 18 year
old guy who uh who's the pool boy if you
like this clip and you want to hear the
whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen